шановні студенти і тренери в це
непростий для нашої держави час вам
випала честь представляти Україну на
найбільших студентських змаганнях
всесвітній зимові універсальні боротьба
обіцяє бути запеклою адже до
американського лейп-лесіду прийдуть
майже півтори тисячі атлетів з 43 країн
світу як і представлять 540
університетів Студентська збірна України
буде представлена у 8 видах спорту в
кількості 601 атлета
кожен ваш старт кожна поява
синьо-жовтого прапору на спортивних
аренах та екранах провідних світових
телеканалів буде надзвичайно цінною та
важливою для нашої країни бажаю гідно
представити Україну і вкотре
продемонструвати
всьому світу що ви найсильніший
вболіваємо за вас Разом до перемоги
тримаємось ми сильні ми Україна З
повагою до вас